Now that we have all
the pieces in place,
we'd like to apply the momentum
principle to the rocket
problem.
Recall that the
momentum principle
is that the external
force on the rocket
causes-- on the system-- causes
the momentum of the system
to change.
And the fundamental
definition of a derivative
is to look at the change in
momentum between sometimes t
plus delta t-- our two states
that we've identified--
divided by delta t.
Now recall that we had
the momentum of the system
at time t was the mass
of the rocket times
d-bar of the rocket a t.
I'll just quickly show
mass of the rocket V-rt.
And we had the system
at time t plus delta t
where we had delta M-fuel equals
minus delta M-rocket Here we
had M-r plus delta M. And we
had the velocity in the ground
frame, which we saw
was equal to-- so let's
write out the momentum of the
system at time t plus delta t.
That was a little bit longer.
p system at t plus
delta t had two pieces.
It had M-r plus delta M-r
times V of r of t plus delta t.
And we were subtracting--
now, because we
made this change, that's
minus then delta M-r u
plus V-bar of t plus delta t.
And this, recall, was
the velocity of the fuel.
Now we're in position to
apply our momentum principle,
because we have expressions
for the momentum
of the system at
time t and at time t
and at time t plus delta t.
So now this will be
a big expression.
So we'll write external force is
the limit as delta t goes to 0.
Now here, our first term, is
of M of r plus delta M-r times
the velocity of the rocket
at time t plus delta t.
And now we have the fuel
term, minus delta M-r times u
plus V of r of t plus delta t.
And we have to
subtract from that
and I'll indicate that with
a slightly different color.
M-r V of r of t.
And the whole thing,
we're dividing by delta t.
Now let's look at
this expression
first because there is some
very nice simplifications.
The first thing we can see,
let's look at this term delta
M-r times V of r.
Notice we have minus
delta M-r V of r here.
So those two terms cancel.
And we're just left
with three other terms
and let's write them out.
So now we have the limit
as delta t goes to 0.
And I'm going to combine
terms in the following way.
M-r times V of r
of t plus delta t.
And over here, I have
M-r minus V of r.
So I have a minus V of r
of t divided by delta t.
And now I have one
more term here.
And I'm going to write this as
minus the limit as delta t goes
to 0 of delta M-r over delta t.
Remember, this term cancelled.
We only have u, the speed of
the fuel relative to the rocket.
And in both cases--
this is our first term
and here's our second term.
Let's look at these limits.
Notice in here,
we're just taking
V of r of t plus delta t minus
V of r-t divided by delta t.
And that's precisely the
definition of the derivative
of the velocity of the rocket.
So this first term,
our expression
becomes the external
force is equal to the mass
of our system times V
of r, the derivative
of the velocity of the rocket.
And the second term,
this is the rate
that the fuel is
changing in the rocket.
This is rather the rate that the
mass of the rocket is changing.
So that's the derivative dM-r
dt times the relative velocity
of the fuel with
respect to the rocket.
So this equation here--
I'll box it off--
is called the rocket
equation, which
we've derived from
the momentum principle
using our momentum diagrams.
And you can see that this
is what people refer to
as rocket science.